Let's go next to our caller from the two oh
six area code. Who's calling today from two
zero six.
Hey, is that me?
Yeah, that's you. Who's this?
Hey, this is Brandon from Seattle. How you
doing?
Good. And we're not on speaker phone or Bluetooth.
Are we Brandon?
Oh, sorry about that.
Oh, okay. Yeah, let's see. Better. Uh, I think
it is. I think it is.
Gotcha. Uh, so my question, uh, revolves around
the recent firing of John Bolton or resentment.
I, I apparently we don't know. Yeah. Um, so
do you think that there will be an overall
net positive change in relationships between
the u s and Venezuela, the u s and then I
ran, I ran, uh, because of somebody like John
Bolton not being in Trump's administrator.
Yeah. I mentioned this in my commentary earlier
this week. It's such an insane situation that
we're in because on the one hand in, in general
politics, John Bolton is one of the most disgusting
Chicken Hawk Neo-con agitators who convinced
George W. Bush about the Iraq war, who, you
know, the guy's just disgusting, truly. And
it's like, it does, what, what war is he not
interested in? At the same time, he does have
more empirical knowledge about what's going
on geopolitically than Donald Trump. And so
I'm sort of at a loss as to it's so it's so
insane to even entertain the idea that we
may be better off in terms of foreign policy
with John Bolton involved than without. But
when you consider that it's Bolton talking
to Trump, I genuinely don't know if we're
better off with him or without him, if it's
Trump left to his own devices as the alternative.
Gotcha. That's, that's the Kinda, that's the,
that's what I'm just gonna have kind of come
to at this point. I, the only problem I'm
struggling with is the fact that, you know,
there are still people like, you know, Mike
Pompeo and Miller in Trump's administration.
Um, I don't think until you get those people
out, there'll be definite change. I am however
hopeful that, you know, maybe, Hey, Trump
didn't agree with Bolton. I ran, I ran, and
that's what, and what's happening with talks
with the Taliban. And hopefully, or maybe
that's what spurred this whole firing. Um,
but yeah, I appreciate your perspective on
it.
Yeah. I mean, the other thing, you know, so,
so like there are certain relationships where
we could argue that, uh, we're certainly better
off without Bolton and there are others where
maybe Bolton's involvement might've been a
moderating influence on the even crazier ideas
that, uh, that Donald Trump had. I, I just
don't know. It's really hard to say on balance.
It's like we just need this entire administration
out. We've got to start from scratch with
a new cabinet. Like these, these people have
all been disastrous.
Oh, I fully agree. These people need to be
expunged from the American political.
Exactly. Exactly. I rode, appreciate the car.
Thank you. Okay.
Appreciate it, David.
Yup. Take care. Bye. Bye. All right, and that
doesn't [inaudible]
recall. Sorry to everybody I didn't get to,
but we did get to many. We will take calls
again. We will take a quick break and I will
be back with plenty more right after this.